oh hey germa oh hey
anyone else here yet uh looks like it's
just us uh I think we're a few minutes
early so
the other bird gets the worms in my
right sorry what I didn't catch that oh
oh no no nothing there never mind I I
just I was just saying oh no no say it
again I want to hear it yeah oh yeah no
I I said that the worms I I mean the no
sorry did the early bird get storms yeah
you get because we're both early you
know oh that's good
so um how's your Christmas break
yeah it was good
um yeah the kids were crazy but uh it
was nice
um uh how about you did you uh spend it
with your family
oh I I I don't celebrate Christmas so I
was just at home
oh
yeah cool
cool
it's weird he should be here um let me
ping him
did you watch the World Cup finals oh my
God yes it was crazy right you know
messing with the two goals and then the
two goal come back it was insane oh wait
actually before I say anything who were
you rooting for
oh I I actually didn't watch the World
Cup uh I'm I'm not I'm not that into
soccer
um I just heard great things about it so
yeah
hey so sorry I'm late
thanks for watching the video appreciate
it as always so I have a huge update
about the future of my channel
um my content is going to Pivot I want
to start making these talking videos uh
kind of like opinion pieces but in video
form I want to do that because there's
lots of stuff going on in the world you
know with AI stuff recessions the
layoffs and how eggs are so expensive
now the cartel smuggling them into the
US I want to share my thoughts with you
guys or even just be informed together
I'll talk more about this change in my
next video but I just really wanted to
give you guys a heads up first you know
I've grown a lot and I've changed a lot
in the past five years and for those of
you who are there from the beginning
would know how different my content was
or how different I was so think of this
as just another chapter also sorry that
I haven't made a video in a while I was
working on myself so thank you very much
for being patient with me and I really
hope that you would enjoy the new videos
that I'll be making so thanks
been acting out for days nothing to deny